so many people know you from the Magic
Mike yeah movies you know that's
probably and they know you from soaps
that you have never live it down but
well no it's a great thing this is very
but how many here's what I'm curious
about how many straight guys come up to
you and say oh I loved you from the
Magic Mike movies yeah quite a few
actually but it's a very covert ops kind
of situation cuz so they feel sick self
Korea surreptitious and it didn't really
start until the first movie came out on
DVD or you know online streaming
whatever yeah they would come up to me
very surreptitious and as I came in I
saw Magic Mike it's pretty good movie
yeah so my girlfriend yeah I was with my
girlfriend yeah yeah we were totally
doing it while we were watching yes it's
so funny to have to give a reason why
yeah you did a striptease in the first
movie yeah it was cut from the film I
was I did all routine where I came out
of the box as the doll and then came to
life as a Ken doll what you know what me
and you have no genitalia maybe that's
why I got cut but know is that you know
these things fall to the floor and
became a DVD extra okay yeah I'll say
yeah and how many times have you watched
it yeah loads yeah
you